foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday February 27th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
I'm going to tell you the story of
reihan ayas it was the early hours of
Thanksgiving weekend last year I was
outside a bar in New York City and my
phone was stolen out from my hands while
it was unlocked and within a few minutes
I tried doing find my iPhone and I was
already locked out of my uplighty almost
immediately the thieves changed her
Apple ID password and the next day she
started to realize this was more than
just a regular phone theft I that point
I realized that there were thousands of
dollars stolen from my bank account in
the form of Apple cash so I contacted my
bank and I went to the police station to
file a police report about ten thousand
dollars was stolen and an Apple credit
card was also opened in her name
according to ayas she's one of many
people to experience this kind of
life-altering theft
our personal Tech columnists Joanna
Stern and Nicole Nguyen have been
investigating how these crimes work and
what iPhone users can do to keep their
information safe Nicole is with us now
to talk about this hi Nicole thanks for
being here hi Zoe thanks for having me
so explain to us what's Happening Here
If a thief takes not only your phone but
finds your passcode I mean obviously
they can get into your phone but why is
it so detrimental to the rest of your
life I think typically when phones are
stolen that was sort of the end of the
story the phone was stolen and then it
was wiped and then it was resold and the
thief would gain cash by reselling the
device but in this case the passcode on
the iPhone gives access to the password
stored in the password manager and it
also allows the thief to change the
password of the Apple ID associated with
the iPhone so the Apple ID controls
iCloud app store purchases it's
everything associated with your Apple
devices am I changing that password you
can force out other Apple devices you
have in your Apple Universe to log out
of that Apple ID and that way people are
completely helpless when a thief steals
their phone and takes over their
financial accounts because they can't
remotely wipe the device the passcode
can also be used for Apple pay for
credit cards that are stored on your
phone and usually one uses Touch ID or
face ID but if that fails then the
passcode is the backup
so if you have credit cards stored in
Apple pay or if you have a debit card
stored in Apple pay that can be used to
fund Apple cash and thieves have used
Apple cash to send money to themselves
another element of this is that some
thieves found sensitive documents like
tax documents that contain Social
Security numbers in the victims camera
rolls and so they were able to open
venmo cards and apple cards on their
behalf take us through the steps that
happen here a thief gets the phone they
get the password what do they do next so
my colleague Joanna and I spoke to
victims all over the country and it
happens a little differently in each
situation but there is a very familiar
process these thieves cozy up to the
victims and befriend them at a bar or
sometimes film them from afar in putting
their passcode and then they take the
phone and immediately the Apple ID
password is changed and the victims
discover over the next several hours
hours or several days that thousands of
dollars have been drained from their
bank accounts or charges have been
wrapped up on their credit cards and
furthermore some of these thieves are
turning on what's called a recovery key
and this recovery key is this new
security feature that's a 28 digit code
and according to Apple's company
policies if you cannot furnish this
recovery key if it's enabled then you
cannot get back into your account the
company does not allow you access to
your Apple account so you no longer have
access to anything stored in iCloud
including
text messages photos contacts notes Etc
how prevalent are these sorts of cases
law enforcement officials have said that
this is a growing concern for them but
we don't know exactly how many types of
these cases are happening across the
country what we do know is that there
have been hundreds of similar cases in
New York and according to court
documents an organized group in
Minnesota affected at least 40 victims
what has Apple said about this situation
an apple spokeswoman has said that they
sympathize with users who have had this
experience and that they will continue
to develop protections to keep user
accounts secure but that ultimately they
believe these attacks are uncommon
because they require both the theft of
the device and the passcode Nicole do
other smartphones have similar issues
Google's Android operating system does
have a similar
passcode to change the password
mechanism however law enforcement
officials told us that iPhones are the
target for these thieves because of
their higher resale value we should also
note that in response a Google spokesman
said that their sign in and account
recovery policies try to strike a
balance between allowing legitimate
users to retain access to their accounts
and keeping Bad actors out so Nicole I'm
sure a lot of listeners are wondering if
I want to keep my phone and personal
information safe what should I be doing
the biggest takeaway we hope readers
have of this piece is to strengthen
their passcode longer passcodes are
harder to what's called shoulder surf
they're harder to Snoop so if you don't
have a six digit passcode that's complex
and one one one one one one does not
count so long and complex passcodes are
the key and if you can enable screen
time protections the same kind of
parental control that adults use with
their children to prevent Apple account
changes on your device without a
separate screen time and passcode all
right that's our personal Tech columnist
Nicole Nguyen thanks for joining us
Nicole thanks Zoe and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing if you want
more Tech stories check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]